so let's talk a little bit about how we
all came into being what we see right
over here this is a picture of a sperm
cell of a sperm cell fusing with an egg
cell so that's the sperm cell and this
is an egg cell or we could call this an
ovum and ovum and even this seen
depicted right over here this is the end
of an epic competition because this
sperm cell is one of two to three
hundred million that is vying for this
ovum so there's two to three hundred
million of these characters and they are
all they're all vying for this ovum and
the one that you see that's about to
fuse for it this is the winner of this
incredibly this is the remember two to
three hundred two hundred million to 300
million sperm are trying to get here so
this is a this is a major victory in to
some degree we should all feel pretty
good about ourselves because we are all
the byproduct of that one in 200 to 300
million sperm cells that won this race
getting to our mother's ovum so the
sperm cell came from our father and the
egg cell this is all happening this is
all happening inside of our mothers the
egg cell is from our mother now once
this happens let's talk a little bit
about the terminology so once these two
fuse we call this prop or the process of
them fusing we call that fertilization
fertile I fertilize eight fertilization
lies ation and it produces a cell that
then differentiates into all of the
cells of our body so you can imagine
this is an important process so let's
make sure that we understand the
different terminology the different
words for the different things that are
acting in this process so thus for each
of the these set each of these sex cells
I guess we could say the sperm cell and
the ovum these are each called gametes
so this right over here is a gamete is a
gamete and the ovum is
a gammy the egg cell is also a gamete
and as we'll see each gamete has half
the number of chromosomes as a as your
body cells or most of your or the
somatic cells in your body so outside of
your sex cells that might be in your in
your oh and your ovaries or your testes
depending on whether you're a female or
female
these have half the number so let's
let's dig a little bit deeper into what
I mean there so I'm going to so let's
just do a blow-up of of this sperm of
the sperm cell right over here so
blow-up of the sperm cell and I'm not
going to draw it to scale you see the
sperm cell is much smaller than the egg
cell but just to get a sense so let me
draw the nucleus of this sperm cell so
just like that if we're talking about a
human being and I'm assuming your human
being so that might be of interest to
you this will have 23 chromosomes from
your father so let's do them 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 and for the 23rd one that's going
to be your sex determining chromosome so
if your father contributes an X you are
going to be female if your father
contributes a Y you are going to be male
so this is this is these are the
chromosomes in the male gamete or I
guess X today through the gamete that
your father is contributing the sperm so
this is a gamete right over here and
then that's going to fuse with the egg
the ovum that your mother is
contributing and once again I'm not
drawing that to scale so this is the
this is the egg and let me draw its
nucleus
so that's its nucleus once again none of
this is drawn to scale and your mother
is also going to contribute 23
chromosomes so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
and then she will contribute an X
chromosome for the sex-determining so
your sex-determining chromosomes are
going to be XY you're going to be male
if this was xx you are going to be
female so this is also a gamete here so
a gamete is the general term for either
a sperm or an egg now once these two
things are fused so once they are fused
what do we have once they're fused then
we're going to have a you could say a
fertilized egg but we're going to call
that a zygote so let me draw that I'll
do this in a new color and I'm running
out of space and I want this all to fit
on the same piece all on the same screen
so I'll draw it not quite at scale and
so let me draw the nucleus of the zygote
I'm going to make the nucleus fairly
large so that we can focus on the
chromosomes in it once again none of
this is drawn to scale so you're going
to have the 23 chromosomes from your
father so let me do that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
and 23 and then the 23 chromosomes from
your mother 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 and 23 so
you got that X chromosome from your
mother and as you might have noticed
I've drawn them in pairs so you now have
a total let me let me make it clear you
have 23 chromosomes here 23 chromosomes
chromosomes in the sperm you have 23
chromosomes 23 chromosomes in the egg
and now you have 46 chromosomes in the
fertilized egg 46 chromosomes and now
that we have a full contingent
of chromosomes and then this cell can
now keep replicating keep splitting and
differentiating into all of what makes
you you we call this right over here we
call this a zygote zygote so one way to
think about it the gametes are the sex
cells that have half the number of
chromosomes and the zygote is the cell
that's now ready to differentiate into
an actual organism that has double the
number or it has that has a full
contingency of korma zomes that has 46
chromosomes and you see it I made them
in pairs and these pairs we call these
homologous pairs and in each of these
pairs this is a pair of homologous
chromosomes pair of homologous
homologous chromosomes chromosomes so
what does what does that mean well that
means that in general these two
chromosomes you've got one from your
father one from your mother they code
for the same things they code for the
same proteins but there are different
variants of how they code for those pros
those proteins those traits that you
have so you know gross
oversimplification is let's say that
there was a gene let's say that there is
a a gene on that one from your father
that helps code for hair color well
there would be a similar there'd be
another variant of that gene on the
chromosome from your mother that helps
code for hair color as well so these are
homologous chromosomes the these two
chromosomes code for in general for the
same things and so the zygote now has
you could say it has 46 chromosomes or
you could say it has 23 pairs of
homologous chromosomes and this is once
again this is the case for human beings
if we're talking about some other
species instead of 23 pairs of
homologous chromosomes or 46 chromosomes
in total you might be talking about 10
pairs of homologous chromosomes with or
to end with 20 chromosomes in general
now to help with biologists to help
clarify when they're talking about the
number of chromosomes for given species
they introduce two words haploid and
diploid
and haploid haploid is referring to when
you have half the full contingency of
chromosomes so for human beings the
haploid number is 23 so this is the
haploid haploid number haploid number
haploid number it is 23 for another
species it would be something else and
haploid is based on the prefix 8 Apple
or that that's that's the prefix for
single so you have kind of a single
member I guess you could think of it of
each of the pair's and now you have you
have both of each pair you have both
chromosomes or in each pair or you have
the full contingency and this 46
chromosomes this is called the diploid
number the diploid number for humans
diploid the diploid number right over
here and when people talk in general and
we will speak in general when we start
talking about mitosis and meiosis for a
given species they will refer to the
haploid number they will refer to the
haploid number as n N chromosomes and
the refer to the diploid number is just
twice that as 2n chromosomes so
hopefully this gets you familiar with
some of the vocabulary around
fertilization and haploid and diploid
and zygotes and gametes and also makes
you feel a little bit better about
yourself that just to exist you at least
I guess half of your chromosomes had to
win an incredibly an incredibly
competitive race